it's awesome i get paid to learn all
these amazing things get in great shape
otherwise i've been like a sloth on the
bean bag watching some football right
like i'm doing now i need to do another
action film so i can get paid to get in
shape
[Music]
dahmer
that was the first time where i you know
i had to play something that existed
embody the person that
existed and not just you know making up
a character right so there's limitations
to to that limitations are are very
helpful
and help guide where you want to go
with what you need to do right all the
other parts are very very difficult
because i
was discovering
what he had done what is you know what
his life was like you know very quickly
and how do i
embody that with truth how's him wise
and what's that that he is and does and
thought and felt and those type of
things so
i had
to do like some work on my own to find
to be courageous enough i mean to be
frank something i had to do is like
you know look at cross sections of
humans and think of it like a playboy
and try to
find some sort of thing to that is being
courageous enough physically emotionally
spiritually mentally to do that right
that allowed me the freedoms to find
some sort of space of where
that brain and spirit is in jeffrey
dahmer right because the guy you guys
just i'm not i can't relate to the guy
but i had to find ways to to do that i
saw this mannequin and i
thought maybe it'd be a challenge if i
could sneak it out without anybody
seeing like a prank
so you uh you still have it
yeah but i'll return it and
this will be over thank goodness i was
actually playing somebody that did exist
because it allowed me to then just focus
on the limitations of how he held
himself how he spoke how he walked and
talked and all that sort of stuff why
don't we just go downstairs go to church
i'll be attentive to everyone's needs
and i will return the mannequin and
it'll be okay it was pretty harrowing to
be honest with you is pretty crazy i
remember my dad saw the film when it
came out
and he couldn't even hug me afterwards
and so i'm like okay good i guess i did
a good job i wasn't quite quite sure
there's just a different entry point
into the the character a lot if it
wasn't somebody that existed it would be
the location and
to determine because we're all products
of our environment you know we talk
about gem from the town that is a
product of an environment of charlestown
and boston the thing that the guy
doesn't exist but you know that
you know certainly formed and shaped who
the character was because of those that
place
um because jeffrey dahmer there's the
limitations of the the person that does
exist
that that formed the uh behavior of the
character yeah jim doesn't exist but he
does exist because there's a version out
there oh there's a thousand of them yeah
all my friends from boston are like dude
i know this guy
you know i mean they're all out there
the town
i have nothing but such fond memories of
that just from
from ben and ellsworth and or dp just
the whole crew everyone behind that is
is a
is stellar at their job and
that's amazing already you know you're
in a winning position
and then to
you know shoot a film
that it's about this very specific kind
of region in that region if we would
have shot that in burbank
california it would have been a hot mess
right but we were able to shoot that
film based upon charlestown in
charlestown right with that community in
charlestown was a very specific
area you know and owen burke being one
of the guys from that area right and ben
was also like the prince of boston you
know being kind of a famous guy there's
a lot of pride in that community
for lots of things but that you know ben
being one of those and i mean it all
informed us to to be the best of what we
could be to help tell that story in that
in that area um and it was awesome we
had just such great experiences and
that's where i learned the accent so i
learned the behavior it's where i
learned that there are five ten fifteen
hundred guys just like jim i met
versions or i just pulled cherry pick
pieces from from people and behaviors
you know
um to find that guy
a guy's walking with two horses right
one horse is carrying 100 pounds the
other one's got 50.
now the 100-pound horse
falls over dead
it's the guy he's like what the [ __ ] he
takes 100-pound sack puts him on the
50-pound horse
and that 50-pound horse he won't move
he won't take one step with another
pound on his back
that's me
this is all i know
yeah i got to spend a lot of time with
with the boys um on and off camera off
camera especially you know to just to
kind of
be more familiar make it easier for our
jobs even and it's also like a very
boston kind of quip you know there's a
sense of humor it can be you know you
demean somebody or a thing you know you
know it's a different thing it's a very
specific thing it's funny [ __ ] to me i
love it
um a lot of people think i'm from that
area i'm like no i just went there to
shoot that film that's it but uh yeah i
have a kinship too to that area i i love
it i love it
i need your help
i can't tell you what it is you can
never ask me about it later and we're
gonna hurt some people
who's car we're gonna take
[Music]
the hurt locker
i had the opportunity to spend a year
with with eod
and did the all the courses that they
did to become eod
how to essentially build bombs and then
render them safe there's a whole like
santa's workshop that they have set up
right and they say santa's workshop
because it looks like just sort of like
a bunch of elves making [ __ ] and then
it's make their make bombs over here and
you go over here and learn how to render
them safe
whether electrical or debt court or you
learn about all these things and then
about bomb making signatures and
all this stuff
and then you put on the suit and there's
a whole test you do a physical
test uh you'll do it for like
you're only supposed to spend about like
15 20 minutes in a soup you do like 30
minutes and your job is to go
you know do all the protocol and then
you find the 155 and you grab it you
know take out the duck cord and take the
155 back which is you know about 75
pounds or 100 pound bomb suit it's 130
degrees
and you do it so you do all the physical
part and a lot of people pass that but
now you do after you finish that bit you
go into the classroom and go to
whiteboard and just do simple division
like you know 7 into 49.
you're just like um you have to kind of
think about it for a minute like it
changed it changes sort of your capacity
to think right where your head's at
where your brain's at because of all the
stress
this is all preparation to understand
that job
the stress the physical stress and the
mental stress the emotional stress all
that sort of stuff and then the mental
toughness that comes out of that
[Music]
now you'd think
these would be like bad ass soldiers
most eod are like look like school
teachers like what i mean they're all
just like look it's pretty much you know
like you're a schoolteacher well for the
most part i mean the guy that trained me
was a big linebacker looking dude
but you know he had the heart and mind
but just you know very sort of
super super super smart they're all very
very very intelligent
so it's a very interesting job to me man
20 meters to the right of the building
he's moving he's moving he's moving to
the building follow him you got him
got him
he's down
good night
thanks for playing there's an intensity
of like you know what this really means
you're just waiting it out right it's
just it's everything's like a chess game
in that film
from again signatures of bomb makers and
what they use and how they do it they
pass notes back and forth between
you know eod and then bomb makers
there's a communication that happens
fascinating to me that that happens
right i'm going to build this bomb and
this [ __ ] is going to see the
note and like oh yeah i got you on that
one or you got me on this one right that
happens crazy i mean i don't think i
ever felt like i was comfortable doing
that in the sense of
that feel the peace but i certainly felt
the my personal effects of being just my
first time ever in the middle east this
is like a white kid from modesto
california going spending so much time
over there in the middle east
and then coming back so my version of
the cereal aisle is going to a starbucks
i was a bit kind of culture shocked when
i got back to the states anyway and all
i could hear is this conversation these
two girls are having about their cracked
toenail polish and i was like
what the
and i went home and i didn't leave for
like 30 days just because of just
culture shock of like has nothing to do
with you know movie or bombs or anything
but i had my own personal version of of
that
and how i had to sort of process that
you know and how i thought about things
and what i was exposed to
um certainly shifted my thinking in a
very big way not that i had been through
war not that i'm a soldier it's none of
those things it's just sort of my
personal experience of like you know
it was harrowing enough just what i did
just in a physical spiritual way with
the
you know just and shooting that thing
shooting that film you know
hawkeye
it's been a wonderful wonderful you know
blessing first and foremost five amazing
friends that we've all shared something
very similar and been through a lot of
things together personally and
cinematically and um we share so much
together that that shared experience is
where where it's all at for me that's a
beautiful thing
and within the world just you know when
it gets the character and stuff there's
always there's like limitations of like
how to really kind of
you know forward the character
understand the character more because
you know everyone's got a
cog in the wheel to to support the whole
picture there's been telling you know
like in the age of ultron when hawkeye
had a family that no one knew about in
this farm in the middle of nowhere and
that was very telling i don't know if
that was written because that's what my
life is because it's a single father and
a thing you know
um doesn't matter if it's cut before the
horse or the chicken or the egg is still
there and i love that that's there
implemented created such a wonderful
grounding rod for people to fly around
or a guy with a hammer can do this and
that uh and laser beam you know all this
sort of stuff there's just a wonderful
grounding rod there's a guy with no
super powers he's got a stick and a
string
he's got a family
right just
there was that said a lot to me about
where the setting intention where that
character is going and ultimately to
where we're at now with this series
is kind of hovering around is no
different than that basic principle you
know sticking a string with family it's
christmas
honey
i'm home
hi
company
sorry didn't go ahead
this is an agent of some kind gentlemen
this is laura
i know all your names
[Music]
oh incoming
high scene hey buddy how you guys doing
dessert look at your face smaller agents
what's the filmmaking process like when
you do a film of this scale new films of
this scale yeah it's just well it's just
different right you you really want to
see
i know what rune river is going to look
like when it's done
i have no idea what the film is going to
look like in the marvel universe i have
zero clue i mean no no the scenes we
shot when it's inside of a lab or
something but like when you don't know
what the backdrop is or like what the
hulk really looks like or all it's just
it's completely different
um but
you know how
what i don't know what it's gonna look
like you know i just don't know but the
process of shooting it some things
inform you like you just focus on what
you do know and don't worry about the
things you don't know or learn about the
things you don't know you know you just
gotta do what you gotta do there's a lot
of stunts also so
and you're wearing the most
inappropriate clothes to do the stunts
you know
it's all that stuff but you know you
just you do the best you can with the
with the limitations and um and
move forward
[Music]
assassination of jesse james by the
coward robert ford
they say that one of the greatest scenes
from a cinematography perspective is the
scene where the train arrives and you
guys do the heist so what was it like
looking at cuz i know that you were only
lit by lanterns and actual trains and we
had bags in our heads so what are we
doing out here freezing i could be
anybody that could be james van der beek
no one will know
sam rockwell and sam shepard and we're
sitting in the woods and it's freezing
it's like four in the morning
i think uh
i think brad pitt's like on with the
lantern or something on the thing trying
to slow the train down wherever the heck
it was i remember this very specifically
this is where i is sitting there and
we're freezing and we're tired and we
get i think rockwell's got his he's got
a couple eye holes and one's like he can
only see that like one eye hole and
we're just laughing at each other
because he
didn't know what's going on and his
burlap sacks are on our heads right
and we're waiting to go rush this train
uh to to rob it
and
i don't know if we ever got to it even
that night i remember all of a sudden
sam shepard just took off he's like you
know forget this i'm out here this is
[ __ ] he just left
and rocco took the thing off he's like
dude winner
i think shepherds took off
like i guess man it's kind of gangster
but like what are we doing here
we're off camera with bags on our head
freezing our asses off he's like should
we go too he's like yeah i think we
should to get out of here we're never
going to get this shot
eventually somehow some way we did get
the shot
[Music]
so
[Music]
if i grew up you know um definitely
riding horses and being in the
countryside and uh is part of my life
and it's something i want to explore
something that was really great about
that movie we had beautiful beautiful
horses that are
disposed at all times just go out and
ride and it was awesome and that was our
job you know in prep for the show i went
out and wrote a lot and that was just
you know it's a great great opportunity
to go do that you know there wasn't a
lot of meat on the bone for me to do a
whole lot in the picture it was a
certain sort of you know chess piece in
that picture there's a lot of time spent
there
i mean i feel like i could have shot all
my [ __ ] out in a you know a week
you know but you know six months you
know i just became a really good rider
you know
[Music]
arrival
there's sometimes you watch a film and
you kind of sit with yourself afterwards
because it's like
it's kind of like really
it's triggered something within you
right
one of those films for me was a rival ah
that's that's funny we said that it's
just such a beautiful film yeah you feel
the same way yeah yeah yeah because i
don't really watch uh just anything i do
except for maybe like a
early cut of something or yeah but
that's exactly the feeling i got when i
saw that didn't know much what was gonna
happen in terms of a very very sparse
film and
uh the character it was was limited in
the sense of what we could tell in the
story because it's a such a rug pull
when i saw that i remember exactly where
i saw it i remember exactly what
happened to me i had to sit and be like
god damn
i mean
that's i said that's a [ __ ] filmmaker
and i walked out and i started weeping
in the parking lot i was just like so
thrown back
by what he was able to put together
because there's some cg there's a lot of
stuff that i wouldn't understand or know
what the film to look like and how would
actually come together so seeing that
wow
that's a filmmaker
[Music]
that film doesn't really have a lot of
of a
green screen
ultimate yeah because any time there was
like a real big effect with the the big
pod you know alien pods were there that
was in the big giant fields and they
would just be able to place that
because it's such a giant landscape you
know there's no
green screen that big it was huge huge
area
now when it came to inside and climbing
up i mean
there was a whole
set built for
you know the whole walk-up and all that
stuff so this whole set so i didn't have
to imagine too much except you know the
the screen was like a big screen we'd
have to look like x's we're not seeing
the actual aliens dancing around they
did have actually puppeteers with long
poles
just to create movement for our eye line
that would move around if they're coming
in and out of those those foggy shadows
right that was nice because it was
interactive because there's a kind of a
puppeteer that we could both follow with
our eye lines what we do for a living
sometimes the person's not even there
when we have to have a scene with them
or it's a tennis ball or it's a green
screen or it's a
you're there but you're supposed to be
the hulk
so what are we gonna call them
i don't know
i was sinking abbott and castillo
yeah
yeah i like it
i like it
[Music]
american hustle
that's a very uh different departure and
also with a very different kind of
filmmaker tremendous cast you're
shooting a movie that's lit for 360
shooting so it's never it's not any
typical kind of filmmaking i remember
running from the camera a lot because
it's i mean literally i ran off set and
i went to the bathroom just so i just
get off camera and stop you know
performing because you just never know
when you're on camera it's just always
got to be in it at all times and start
making up lines and i was in a character
you know playing a politician and only i
i only had so much
that i could sort of like you know
do
that's not written or scripted and i had
to sort of like you know riff on he's
going to grow our tax base and create
thousands and thousands of jobs for
everyone you understand that
you know what that means
derpy
come on this guy right here he's got a
big heart
just hate it if it didn't work out
what do you mean of course it's gonna
work out or if come on guys like you and
me
come on man right we dream and we build
we never give up we never quit
after like 10 minutes riffing i'm like
okay i'm out i'm tapped out i got
nothing left to say i just really would
go off and just walk off set and they'd
follow me with the camera into the
bathroom i'll go back i'm like dude
we're at craft services you can't film
me here
i mean it's like just so crazy
but
there's something very kinetic about
that style of filmmaking and very alive
um which is fun and
and david russell he just has such a big
heart and
smartness to to what he does and it's
always very character driven great
characters and a ton of great actors and
a great director and
you know
it was uh it was a lot of work but it
was a lot of fun
it's a boring legacy
yeah i was a fan of those films
and
getting the opportunity to do that you
know it's kind of the opposite of like
marvel or those kind of action films is
because it's all very real
that it still felt like shooting one
legacy like it was a small little
independent film there was only a few it
was me and rachel vice and
or just me or just you know one dude or
three dudes that beat up and then move
on it's a very small sort of feeling
it's except for a few big action set
pieces but it's very you know close kind
of filming not like you know trying to
grab big vistas
you know it's very very very boots on
the ground very very in your face type
of filmmaking i love that the process
because i just you know we can move fast
and get things done and you don't want
to hurry up and wait we just heard me
get it done and we just kept moving
because there's not a lot of things we
had to worry about this is about me
running across this wire okay draw the
wire hooked up here and do these things
you've got to learn all those amazing
things i was already prepared because of
my experience like with tom cruise and
teaching me understanding you know this
is a is a different part of the job but
a very very thing you take serious and a
lot of training eight hours a day for
five months and
that's a lot a lot of work
that was a warner so
it's
i'd
a three-story building coming from a
basement and uh parkour up the thing
good thing go up you know it's the whole
thing
did that 18 times and i did have i had a
harness on with a small pick in case i
got tired to
you know one of the times it's got to be
all fluid and it all had to be like with
the camera all the wander right
i ended up using the second take
but i was like ah i feel like i could do
it better but i did like 18 times and it
was exhausting but but it's because all
one or so many things were variables
with a camera movement and a thing and
knee movement and making sure it's all
in focus and come in the thing and then
shoot the guy down at the bottom of the
stairs right it's a very specific thing
but you know it was a fun thing to
communicate with camera guy and the guy
in the wire and the thing to all make it
work but
um they use the second take you know but
whatever that's my job i'm the one i
kept asking for another take anyway so
i was a ratchet um and sometimes it's
just a couple of guys yanking on you and
enough to pull they may have done one if
it's a longer wide shot they may have
used one where
they'll use an actual like machine or
some sort of compression thing that you
did for a big yank the water in that
scene that you cannot fake that was like
below freezing water that was brutal it
just cut me out of the water and by the
time i got to the edge there's icicles
that formed on my beard
before i got out of that water it was
crazy and it was real oh yeah
and again that's where it's like another
one or waiting for the helicopter shot
getting out of the water and the whole
thing and it's like all right let's do
another one but while i'm still
ready and freezing to go again you know
it was a it was pretty cool
a lot of challenges for that kind of
stuff
[Music]
wind river
you know the big impetus for for taylor
to write
wind river i mean because about two
tribes on at one river and
this is one specific thing but it's
something that happens often that's the
the big kind of umbrella theme and
something that a lot of people don't
know and creating some light on on that
there's not a lot of policing it's not a
thing that's a cultural thing that
happens and it's tragic is all hell
right but then we still have to tell our
story and this is a
character that unlike dahmer who's very
very close to me i live in that kind of
environment i
everything about that guy is very very
similar to
me you know in physical ways in in
the more moral ways
um very very close right and then you're
talking about
you know death of
young girls and that type of thing and
then also corey you know like the
character i played lost his child it was
pretty it was pretty intense it was it
was a lot it was a lot to to handle and
it was good that that character held a
lot close to his vest you know was a
just a man of action and not a lot of
words and it's nice to have lizzie you
know someone i was comfortable with
already in the
and that just in the acting world and
she's terrific but it was it was a very
difficult
uh time
if you can make to that highway
you're a free man
where where's where's the highway
you know how far that drill camp was
from where i found natalie's body
six miles
barefoot
that's a warrior
that's a warrior
you you made me 600 feet i think we're
about 12 000 feet elevation that was
beautiful beautiful vista but yeah we
had to be kind of harnessed in for a lot
just for the safety of
we had very little places to shoot up
there and it was a big big scene you
know
actually that actors and i'm working
worked with for mayor of kingstown the
same actor it's funny i just we just
spoke together about that scene recently
so funny it's fresh in my brain
[Music]
mayor of
kingstown how was ed
uh
tim weaver's nephew got hooked
you know the letter some low-level crypt
on hopeful sanctions
yeah that's a
a departure from what uh taylor's
written in the past where it's it's
usually more rural and
um
you know cowboy or just kind of kind of
with the land this isn't a very more
urban prison town but what taylor always
does
is he writes very truthful raw you know
it's not always pleasant and that's
where it's very truthful
it's very poetic
very
tender as it is violent so that can be
expected
but just now set in a prison town
where the business of incarceration is
the only business
and i play a character called the
mayor's mayor
mike mccluskey who is the greece uh that
uh lubricates the whole engine of that
that prison town and in the process of
it for the from the prisoners to the
to the guards to the all around in and
out of that town he's a good guy he can
do bad [ __ ] to you though
yeah
he'll do whatever it takes to keep to
peace yeah he would he's there he's he's
not a bad guy at all he's pretty a self
a very selfless guy which is pretty
admirable i think
yeah
yeah yeah me too